is it is it true that you got in trouble
for showering at a gas station once
because i need the story
[Laughter]
um it nearly got me arrested that's true
i was
i was traveling around america as a
young young traveler i was about 20
21 at the time and i just slept in my
car because i couldn't find a room that
night
and i needed to freshen up in the
morning kelly as you as you do
and i couldn't find a shower anywhere
but i found a gas station that was
closed and i realized that you know well
the tap is is there and i'll just kind
of
try and freshen up under the tap so i
was
sitting on the ground on the concrete
trying to freshen up
i want to say i was clothed that's when
i say i was clothed okay and
i wanted to get my head underneath and
as a lot of tall people struggle with
when you're staying in a cheap hotel
when the
force doesn't quite make you know you've
got to do that thing where you kind of
bend down and get underneath
when i was trying to
it has its advantages when you're on the
road kelly as you know
yes no it is nice so i was literally you
know
in a kind of contortionist position
under this tap and
someone in an apartment building next
door yelled out you know you can't do
that
sir you cannot take a shower under a tap
and call the police and the police came
and i
my excuse was i said i'm sorry but i'm
australian
and i don't have anywhere to anyway i
didn't get arrested kelly
and um i i i can't remember if i found a
shower that day or not actually
but um there you go oh i hey i had a
civil experience
it wasn't in public but i my place
burned down um here in l.a when i was
like a teenager i moved out here
and i had nowhere to go but i had a gym
membership so i think they started
noticing i was just like taking
showers and like getting for my job
she's skipping the workout she's coming
in for the shower but i didn't see the
bit where she
wasn't working out you know around
opening time to get ready for
it hey you have to do what work yep i'm
still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever